okay so the latest episode of House of
the Dragon has two subtle things that
definitely need to be discussed in more
detail the first of these is the passing
of viserys and how the book and show
give us a clue to how there might be
some foul play involved the second
involves Helena's prophecy and the major
event that the Beast beneath the boards
could be referring to throughout this
video we're going to be breaking it all
down and as we go through them I'd love
to hear your perspective on whether you
agree or not now viserys's death is a
big way to close out episode 8 and have
even seen some comments saying this
would have been the perfect way to end
the season it brings a lot with it and
though it seemed like he died of natural
causes there may be something else going
on now in order to fully discuss this
Theory we have to talk about what the
book says it's important to bear in mind
that Fire and Blood is basically a
textbook compiled by maesters that pulls
in several accounts to try and paint a
picture of what happened though most say
that viserys died in his sleep during a
nap there were some suspicions that
Alison had poisoned him this was done to
his hippocrats which in the show has T
but either way this was basically
brought in to help with his health
conditions the show clearly planted a
lot of seeds for this to be the case too
and back in episode 6 lanor said this to
an Era when she suggested leaving King's
Landing you always said if you were
absent from court she would pour her
honey in your father's ear knowing the
books this line really stood out to me
because it sounded like they were giving
nods to us conspiracy theorists that
something else might be going on the
final picture in the book shows for
Sarah's looking in pretty good health
whereas the show has him rotting away
from the inside almost like he's being
poisoned over time to watch someone
wither away like this is extremely
strange oh you've never really seen it
happen to another character in Game of
Thrones history viserys was also
surrounded by the best maesters in the
land and he would have had a medical
team Fit For A King that would normally
know how to deal with most ailments
however a slow poisoning is something
that I might not be able to handle due
to how long it takes the Macy's also
changed out too and in the latest
episode we get Orwell due to the death
of malos this chaining of the Guard
would have likely meant that they
couldn't carry across an opinion on him
and thus the high Towers could have kept
it under the radar I'm clearly not the
only person who suspects this either and
after passing him his quote-unquote T
Damon ends up sniffing it to see if
something else is inside it turns out
that this is apparently milk of the
poppy which is being used to help keep
him sedated milk of the poppy is
basically morphine and it has several
side effects though it can be used to
reduce pain it also leaves someone
unable to think properly this allows
Alison and Otto to take control of the
council and in the end they use this to
their benefit now this drink is also
something that Alison gives to viserys
just before he passes away potentially
this train could have slowly been
poisoning him over time and this was the
final little dose that pushed him over
the edge in these two scenes viserys
takes the tea but there is one where he
turns it down that could speak volumes
to how this was slowly killing him in
the scene where he has his wounds tended
to other goes to offer him the drink but
viserys ends up saying no later that day
he regains his strength to the point
that he can go to the throne room and
climb the iron steps for one final time
he also attends a banquet between the
two families it's only once he has the
tea that he ends up dying and this could
have been the thing that pushed him over
the edge the episode also shows us how
much Alison has changed and that she
clearly isn't above using poisons and
toxins either this is demonstrated
through her maidservant who Alison ends
up giving the Plenty two in order to
stop her from having a child so she's
definitely accustomed to using drinks as
a way to get what she wants and I've
even seen come and saying they suspect
that she might have poisoned her servant
the show also uses a lot of symbolism to
demonstrate its points too and clearly
they place people around the table to
hint who the rotten ones are due to his
eye falling out and his cheek rotting
away viserys has one side of his face
that makes him look like Harvey Dent on
a good day during the banquet the family
sit to his left and right with renira
and Co being on the good side whilst the
high towers are on the other this
symbolizes that they are the ones
causing him to rot away and that the
other side of the family were the ones
he favored the most it's excellent
iconography and to me it helps to hint
towards the fact that they were
instrumental in his downfall they were
very much the rats that came for him in
the end and this has been shown in the
show at several points firstly there was
the one at the wedding that appeared
right after he collapsed next was
another that climbed into his room now
in the books Alison doesn't announce
viserys's death for a week and this is
how she can put things in place to get
us an egg on on the throne she leaves
his corpse in his Chambers and Rats
start to feed on it but the idea of this
may extend beyond them literally the
rats are now here in the form of the
high Towers most notably Alison who
gives in that final drink though they
might not have poisoned him literally
the family clearly had a negative effect
on him and this caused him to run away
even more now whether Alison did it on
purpose or not here's another thing that
I think we'll never get a full answer to
however there are enough Clues there I
think to make us believe that something
else could have been going on and of
course love to hear your thoughts on it
before we get into Helena's prophecy and
also really appreciate the thumbs up if
you're enjoying the video so far and
don't forget to subscribe for breakdowns
like this every day you will suggest
launched Eclipse Channel which drops
minute long short videos discussing
Easter eggs theories and heavy spoilers
highlights make sure you hit that up as
we're almost at 4 000 subscribers and
we'd love to have you as part of our
house anyway Helena throughout the
series has dropped a number of
prophecies that have hinted out things
coming down the line the first of these
came when she correctly guess that Eamon
would have to lose an eye in order to
gain a dragon you will have a dragon one
day he'll have to close an eye I know it
the second came when she for told the
marriage between raniera and Damon's
flesh weaving dragons of threat and the
last episode Peter's aligned from her
that could bring a lot of things with it
now the Beast beneath the boards could
refer to a number of things viserys hits
the floor with his staff as she says
this so it could be her warning him of
the rats beneath his floorboards this
could either be Alison or the literal
ones that we talked about before but
yeah that is definitely the potential
here that he's referring to him however
it may extend beyond that and it could
indeed be aemond with an ex part of the
video dealing in future events I'm gonna
have to drop in a spoiler warning so if
you don't want the show ruined then
check out now now when the house is
about divided the suns were sent out to
try and gain people loyal to their cause
both luceris and Eamonn ended up going
to Lord boroughs with the ladder
arriving there first he ended up
promising that he'd wear one of boris's
daughters if the Lord pledged his
allegiances to the greens lucerus
couldn't do the same as he was already
betrothed to his cousin and this boros
ended up siding with aemond aemond also
demanded an iron return and he said that
he'd let Luke live if he could out one
right there and then lucerus didn't and
though Eamon went to attack he was
stopped by Lord boris's men borrow said
that he wouldn't allow any Bloodshed
under his roof and this amen followed
look out and tracked him on his Dragon
his storm then broke out and Eamonn
ended up killing Luke which led to him
being known as the kin Slayer so
potentially it could be him however the
Beast beneath the boards could also
refer to mizaria we've seen that she has
spies and informants in King's Landing
most notably the Queen's right-hand
woman there is potential at the plant he
she prepared didn't actually contain
anything and due to egg on having two
bastards in the book this might end up
coming true if it didn't work but I
digress now mazoria is known as the
white worm and she also does something
in the book that directly affects Helena
after lucerys is killed Damon promises
his son for his son and he goes to
Missouri for help she sends two people
into the castle and they use the secret
passages in order to sneak into Helena's
room these are the characters blood and
cheese and they've basically been told
them kids they find her and her children
children and deliver the ultimatum that
one has to live and one has to die she
ends up choosing the younger one mailer
to be murdered which is a really
heartbreaking moment however to make
things worse blood and cheese without a
moment's hesitation end up beheading
joharis instead it's one of the most
horrifying moments in the book that I
want to do a full breakdown on at some
point but I think the prophecy could be
referring to this they climb from
beneath the floorboards and the word
Beast being used for the White Worm does
definitely work after this Elena has to
deal with the fact that her youngest
child knows that she picked them to die
and she also has to Grapple with losing
her other kid the devastating moment for
her that ends up selling her insane I
think this could be referring to this
and if she prophesizes the worst moment
of her life at this point then it would
add an even further tragic side of the
supper personally that's the one I'm
leaning towards but obviously all these
videos are theories and if you have your
own then make sure you drop them below
we are in a competition right now giving
away three copies of dolom and thunder
on the 15th of October and all you have
to do to be when the chance of winning
is make sure you subscribe with
notifications on drop a comment below
with your thoughts on the episode and
also best best theory wins now if you
want something else to watch make sure
you check out one of our house of the
Dragon breakdowns which will be linked
on the screen right now we've got loads
that we've done we're milking it dry so
yeah definitely head over there right
after this by the way thanks for singing
through the video that'll be important
I'll see you next time take care peace